i like to think that you know a lot of
life is about relationships and loving
each other and this and that you know
and uh you know i've read i've done my
fair share of reading on like eastern
philosophy and you know eliminating the
ego eliminating desires and you know all
of that jazz and i realize that that's
really great to like be able to like you
know conquer
conquer like some peace inside of you
you know and be able to like do that i
think after you do that though if you're
gonna be in the world that i'm in
you need to you need to also like
conquer war you know and you need to
learn a lot about that and you need to
and you need to know how to get there
when i lost my first fight i had to
really do some searching you know
i spent about six months probably you
know thursday to sunday every day in the
mountains either camping or hiking or
both
and that's kind of where i learned to
like meditate learn to silent my mind
um and just kind of you know like listen
to that little ego that's inside your
head because it'll chirp off you know
like it still chirps off no matter how
much
i feel like i do still you know of
course uh
so man like i i know that it's in there
right like i know that you know uh
it's in there like it wants power it
wants to conquer it wants to it wants
things you know like every need is an
ego to feed there's a you know a bob
marley from a bob marley song but uh
it's still in there man but i think it's
just more about like how how do you
respond to it best in a way where it
doesn't impact relationships with
yourself uh and with other people
because i mean at the end of the day man
like we're humans we're social animals
like i think that that's more or less
why we're on the planet is to interact
and to love each other and all of that
jazz um
and i think that if you let your ego get
in the way of those types of things
that's where the ego really is taking
over your life you know so i just try to
keep it right underneath that but but
right at the level where it's like nah
but when i go in the cage i'm still
trying to you know win and
and get all the things i want because i
want a lot of things in my life right
yeah so still able to like
just kind of almost corral it like at
least have some control over it
sure that's interesting yeah i think
meditation is probably really really key
to that kind of stuff you know do you do
it
i don't do it as much as i as i should
and i can feel when i'm not doing it
yeah yeah i can feel like
like
the
uneasiness inside of me the uncertainty
yes and i can feel it start to push from
the inside of me out towards onto my
like the inside of my skin yeah
so it's funny when i know i have more
control over that like um things roll
off my shoulders easier i don't give in
to like a lot of the traps of my brain
and of society
and um i'm a little bit more in control
of myself and then i feel like i can
also do my best work than just as a
human yeah not even as like a
comedian or podcast or but just as a
human as a brother as a son as a
friend as a co-worker all that kind of
stuff you know
what uh how do you make the clutter go
away then
um i think a lot of times i'll use yoga
right now and then i just started
getting into doing um jiu jitsu nice i'm
white belt hell yeah so they give it to
you when you get there but i am uh i'm
certified white belt so
uh
yeah so that's been cool man i never
realized how much um
anger i had in this this goes back to
what you were asking me about my answer
to that question was
man when i like about two years ago i
kind of got into a space where i was
just getting more popular
and um
and i think something
i had a lot of anger i got a lot of
anger because i i i think i always
thought inside of myself when i got to a
certain level of
achievement whatever we view achievement
as or success whatever it doesn't have
to be monetary success but it could just
be
a platform or finally having your voice
heard or
um
finally achieving your physical
potential like just if when i got to a
certain level of success that i was
going to feel
a level of accomplishment that that
matched it or that
i don't know that the world was going to
be different suddenly the problems the
uncertainties the
the low self-worth all that [ __ ] would
be completely gone
and i think when i started to arrive at
some of those places it wasn't
and i realized you're still just
stuck with just re just life yeah that
you know like it still pisses you off
when someone cuts you off in traffic
yeah everything's still never gonna go
away yeah you're still life doesn't come
out and say there's nothing that there's
not like a magical waterfall that opens
up and a man or woman walks out and says
congratulations you did it yeah there's
never that thank you for your effort
um
i think there's something inside of me i
think it got so angry because there
wasn't like a
you know you don't get the golden orb or
whatever that quidditch ball you don't
get you know there's no big thank you
for your effort yeah
and uh and that made you angry it made
me angry i didn't know what was going on
it was just inside of me and so i think
i got so angry
and i was having trouble finding a place
to put it
and then
since i started going to the jujitsu gym
man i get
it literally has to come out of me
because i'm [ __ ] caged up by some 50
or 60 year old man yeah and i can't
[ __ ] do anything you know or they put
me against some [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
adderall
6'5 guy the white belts are the most
dangerous guys bro
i'm fighting a guy that drives a bread
truck dude all night he hasn't even
slept and he's in there the guy's
[ __ ] jacked just taking caffeine
pills before bro that's a real thing man
we got a couple guys like that too at
the gym it is crazy bro so but just my
me wanting to wanting something and not
having any control over it that's those
moments where i'm just caged up i can't
move somebody i can't and i'm trying
with part muscles in my nut muscles i
didn't even know were in my body i'm
trying with and having no
and there's no return from the world
yeah and it's like it kind of answered
that
that question that i had where i wanted
some return and then it's like jiu jitsu
shows you that there's just
there's no return but it's kind of okay
yeah and you go back to a place where
you each shake each other's hand and
it's all good and
and you try and learn a different way
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one
you